Now, I think we're at a point where we can really help Grant solve this
inequality. We have the quantity 15 plus x times the quantity 20 plus x, less
than or equal to 750 to describe how the expanded side links of his booth area
will determine a total area that needs to be less than or equal to 750 square
feet. What I'd like you to do know is do a little bit of algebra. To get this in
a quality in a form so that we can have 0 on the right hand side and then an
expression on the left hand side, so I would like you to start out actually by
simplifying the expression on the left and then getting rid of the 750 on the
right side, in other words, I'd like you to simplify the left-hand side of the
inequality as much as you can.